[Music]
the team behind marvel's midnight suns
are best known for xcom the stellar
tactical strategy series about sending
squads of elite soldiers against an
invading alien force and often watching
those soldiers die horrifically the
logical pitch for midnight suns then is
x-com but with superheroes but in fact
the new marvel title from developer
faraxis games is much more rpg than
strategy game this isn't another xcom
it's something very different as for
raxis notes midnight suns focuses on
some of the more spooky elements of the
marvel universe including its more
arcane heroes the initial premise is
pretty standard the evil military group
hydra uses some occult weirdness to
resurrect a supervillain named lilith
the mother of demons and starts aiding
her and taking over the world to combat
that threat characters like doctor
strange and iron man band together with
more supernaturally inclined folks from
around the marvel universe such as blade
ghost rider and magic included in that
group is the hunter a fully customizable
character you create who is also
lilith's child and the chosen one who
can stop her once and for all but first
let's talk about midnight sun's approach
to tactical combat back when it first
started showing off the game paraxis
revealed that it uses card based deck
building mechanics for its battle system
each character in your combat team of
three has a handful of cards that
represent their abilities and when you
start your turn in a battle you draw a
hand of random cards you can play a set
number of cards per turn so which ones
you draw determine what your characters
can do it's a system that seems
drastically different from the tactical
approach that xcom players are used to
in the xcom games each character you use
has a set of actions or abilities they
can use each turn but each of those
abilities has a percentage attached to
it that tells you its chances of hitting
or missing as creative director jake
solomon explained during our play
session though the idea of characters
missing their attacks or their attacks
having a chance to do low damage broke
the fantasy of controlling an awesome
superhero team but some degree of
randomness is essential for making
tactical games fun and unpredictable
farax's solution was to move that
randomness to character abilities
forcing you to think carefully about
which cards to play when and in what
order to maximize your team's
effectiveness your abilities come with a
lot of caveats and additional effects
making team synergy and careful planning
extremely important for instance some
attack cards come with the knockback
effect where the enemy you hit can be
sent flying if you crash them into an
object you can deal extra damage send
them into another character and you can
hurt them both quick attacks give you an
extra card play in your turn if you kill
the enemy you're attacking since you can
only play three cards in a turn having
quick cards can extend your actions
significantly you also need to think
about which enemies you target since
your cards will automatically move your
characters around the battlefield which
is sometimes essential to keeping them
out of harm's way from a coming attack
or effect playing cards also builds up a
resource called heroism which is another
key element of your planning your more
powerful cards require you to spend
heroism to use them so you want to build
up your stock for those big moments
where you can do things like drive ghost
rider's bike through multiple enemies or
bombard the battlefield with iron man's
missiles but you can also use heroism
without cards spending heroism can allow
your characters to interact with the
environment like throwing a rock at an
enemy or blowing up an explosive barrel
if you've got enough heroism the
environment can give you what are
essentially additional attack
opportunities it all works together to
create a different tactical feel from
x-com thinking through your options and
abilities is often about clearing out as
many enemies as you can in one go or
knocking out the enemies focusing their
attacks on one of your squad members in
order to reduce the amount of damage
they'll take next turn you need to think
about controlling your positioning
clearing out important enemy threats
building heroism to execute big
abilities and more it creates a puzzle
that is similar to xcom but also feels
completely different in the moment the
card system introduces randomness into
battles that makes them feel variable
and interesting decks are relatively
small and easily tuned and you have the
opportunity to redraw specific cards
each turn so you never feel like you're
getting beaten by a bad hand from the
rng the characters you bring into fights
also add a lot of variety to your
tactical considerations because of their
different abilities and roles blade for
instance is a damage focused character
great for taking out tough enemies
because he can inflict the bleed status
effect that causes them to lose health
over time doctor strange can boost his
teammates and in so doing his attacks
become more powerful you can also adjust
each character's deck as you earn more
cards through midnight sun's crafting
system allowing you to focus on specific
aspects of their abilities but each
character's deck never has more than
about 8 cards in it so it never gets too
complicated farax's also made a big deal
of the hunter the hunter has a variety
of abilities that span from straight
damage dealing to support and healing as
well as an alignment meter that ranges
from light to dark the hunter's
alignment changes depending on the cards
you play support cards tend to be light
damage cards tend to be dark which
changes their effectiveness so the
character reacts to how you tune your
hunter's deck and according to your
playstyle becoming more powerful in your
dedicated area and if you choose to
generalize taking on abilities from all
over the spectrum your alignment
reflects that too the alignment system
isn't just about battles and cards
though it's an rpg system that keeps
track of your choices and dialogue as
you work through the story and interact
with members of your team as the hunter
and there's a surprisingly huge amount
of dialogue to work with midnight suns
tracks the flow of time in a way that's
similar to xcom limiting the actions you
can take during each in-game day at the
start of a day you wake up in the abbey
the midnight sun's base of operations
where you can run around having
conversations with characters chasing
down collectibles and advancing story
beats and interacting with the crafting
system that can earn you new cards at
some point you'll eventually pick a
combat mission to take on the further in
the game you get like x-com the more
missions become available and you can
choose to take on key story battles or
go after more generic ones that offer
resources you might need after your
mission for the day you return to the
abbey at night where more story unfolds
in fact a huge part of the five hours we
played were dedicated to walking around
as the hunter in the abbey learning
about the various elements of the game
there are a lot of tutorials strung
together as part of the narrative in the
early part of the game as midnight suns
gives you the lowdown on combat dialogue
mechanics team building elements such as
training to boost your card's
effectiveness crafting and more but the
game doesn't seem to have more systems
than you'd expect from say the base
building side of xcom what was
surprising was how much of those
tutorials are built into the
storytelling and character interaction
during the session solomon said that the
midnight sun's team kept finding that
they wanted to spend more time with the
characters the draw for them was as much
about the personalities of the
superheroes and their friendships and
rivalries as it was about using them in
battle alongside conversations you can
have with characters as the story
progresses which come with a variety of
dialogue options the nighttime portions
of each day give you opportunities to
hang out with one specific character all
that time with your team plays into the
friendship system which allows you to
unlock better ability cards and more
synergy with your teammates based on how
close your relationship with them is it
incentivizes hanging around with the
other superheroes as well as learning
about them blade for instance isn't a
fan of your snarky jokes while magic
appreciates it if you can relate to the
darker elements of her past phyraxis
said the dialogue options won't change
the flow of the narrative but it
definitely will affect your
relationships with different characters
and you can only choose one character to
hang out with for a given day so your
choices for dealing with other
characters affect both how your
particular story plays out as you learn
more about each person and some heroes
more than others and how your team
functions in battle the tone feels a bit
more in line with something like the
avengers films or the guardians of the
galaxy with plenty of quips and humor
between the characters and tons of
references to the marvel universe
tony that's uh carol and dr spooky over
there
here to help somewhat coincidentally the
game's story actually has a lot in
common with a recently released movie
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness despite fibraxis beginning the
development of its tale some five years
ago expect to see a big cross-section of
the marvel universe take part in the
game as well the portion we played
included missions with spider-man on the
team fighting a demonic version of venom
who had been possessed by lilith
marvel's midnight sons was surprising in
that while it looks a bit like the x-com
games it tends to feel drastically
different from them it's also a major
departure from phyraxis usual offerings
with an increased focus on storytelling
and rpg elements that go far beyond the
combat at its center but while midnight
suns is a little out of phyraxis
wheelhouse it was also fun to play its
battle system puts a big spin on the
underlying ideas of tactical turn-based
combat that also feels more approachable
than the slightly more hardcore focus of
xcom although we also saw that midnight
suns will offer a bunch of high
difficulty options so you can really
challenge yourself and it's storytelling
though dense puts a lot of emphasis on a
group of deep and interesting characters
over the course of 60 hours it seems
there will be a whole lot to explore in
midnight suns and from what we've seen
so far
uncovering secrets building
relationships and mastering combat
mechanics are going to be rewarding for
strategy and rpg fans alike how about i
take eddie here for his afternoon walk
don't worry doc that's just his way of
saying he cares